fait on a été effectivement ce matin au
siège de la république en marche on a
déposé deux montagnes de compteurs linky
pour dénoncer ce qui est en train de se
passer la place du service public de
l'énergie puisque avec le port hercule
pour l'électricité le plan clamadieu
pour le gaz
ils vont saucissonné et détruire le
petit reste de service public faire
exploser les prix pour les usagers faut
savoir qui a déjà 13 millions de
français qui sont en situation de
précarité énergétique qui ne peuvent
donc plus se chauffer et là ils vont
essayer de vendre à la vente à la
découpe
tout ce qui reste de production de
transport de distribution d'électricité
et du gaz à des sociétés privées donc
nos vieillards de la cage chez nous mais
il va y avoir effectivement de la
spéculation en sachant qu effectivement
maintenant depuis plus de quinze ans de
privatisations il ya eu 80 %
d'augmentation des prix du gaz pour tous
les français et 40 % d'augmentation des
prix l'électricité donc le symbole c'est
à dire comme la république en marche et
derrière et que c'est elle qui pousse
pour cette privatisation et cette
destruction de du service public de
l'électricité
on est laide père pour leur dire qu'on
se laissera pas faire qu'évidemment on
veut stopper ces projets mais à l'est
plus encore aller sur des luttes
offensives nationaliser nos entreprises
les mettre sous contrôle
effectivement des salariés des
représentants des salariés et des
usagers pour que l'électricité le gade
redeviennent ce qu'ils essaient tête du
temps du service public c'est à dire un
bien fondamental c'est pas une
marchandise c'est pas du bon mot et des
cacahuètes et on veut que ce bien là ils
soient reconnues d'utilité nationale et
que aucun français françaises quelle que
soit sa classe sociale son origine me
manque d'électricité ou de gaz
parce qu'il n'ya pas de démocratie quand
vous pouvez pas vous chauffer chez vous
et le sens du combat pour ça qu'on est
venu où joue aujourd'hui avec les
copains du spectacle c'est à dire que
l'attak elle est massive elle est
globale en france aujourd'hui sur toute
la population et qu'il faut que la
réponse est soit massive et globale qu
on y aille tous ensemble avec les gilet
jaune léger les rouges toutes les
corporations et qu'on stoppe ce
gouvernement qui est en train d'oeuvrer
contre les intérêts du peuple et de la
nation